bonjour amadou bâ
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct dans la matinale d'ayrté
france premier déplacement dans tony
blinken en afrique il commence par le
kenya c'est un nouveau souffle que
veulent insuffler les états unis
écoutez nous pouvons dire que c'est une
reprise des affaires entre les états
unis et ses partenaires crédit chinoise
quelqu'un se soit le kenya le nigeria le
sénégal qui en clients des relations
diplomatiques assez large depuis tant
d'années avec les états unis donc où on
peut dire que c'est un signal fort pour
la reprise des affaires et de
renforcement des échanges commerciaux et
économiques entre ces deux
alors au coeur de cette première visite
à nairobi la situation au soudan et en
ethiopie quelles sont les intentions des
deux parties sur ce dossier
euh vous savez que antoine buteur s'est
pas
très bien
dans ces régions il ya beaucoup de
questions dont le taylorisme les
questions politiques relatives aux
événements liés aux élections
présidentielles au niveau des kenya au
niveau aussi la ligue compte boko haram
et à al qaïda au niveau du sahara
occidental vers le nigeria est aussi le
sénégal qui est un partenaire
stratégique que vous l'avez contre le
terrorisme
donc donc anthony blinken et est venu
renforcer cette coopération contre le
terrorisme
on sait que la france déjà été engagés
au sahel vous parlez de du terrorisme
djihadiste que peuvent faire de plus les
américains dans cette région
elle sait que tu vois il y faut ni non
seulement militaire mais aussi pour
renforcer aussi les partenariats
économiques y lit ses partenaires
américains dans le cadre du m6 m6 si les
millénium vacances et aussi dans le
cadre du du programme africa qui a été
initiée à la fin
du règne de 30 en 2020 avec un programme
de 500 millions de dollars pour relancer
les investissements et les accords
économiques et les états unis d afrique
et aussi les coups d'état successifs que
l'on a que l'on a vu en afrique est ce
que c'est un problème est qu'elle
quelques opérations peuvent faire les
états unis dont sept dans ce domaine
non seulement les américains peuvent
traiter idées des conseils auprès des
chefs d'état africains mais aussi du
président auditionné dalle qui doit
prendre la présidence de l'union
africaine du 2022 à 2023 bons coups le
sénégal devienne un partenaire si en
interne le seuil pour pouvoir discuter
de cette question au niveau de l'union
africaine à travers les six retards
parce que pour l'accueillir non
seulement des informations et dégager
ensemble une stratégie militaire pour
apporter son soutien à 6 c'est que les
écarts mot jours n'oubliez pas que le
sénégal a reçu en 2006 la plus grande
exercice n'est guère d'effort solitaire
américaine aussi son terrain qui
s'appelle synox 2016 le sénégal aussi
aujourd'hui on peut dire que quand qui
suit le z5 celle en tant que partenaire
première au niveau
de la fois sur une dizaine au niveau du
mali on sait que la chine est aussi
implanté donc dans cette région
particulièrement au kenya ce qu'il n'y a
pas une sottise concurrence qui est en
train de s'installer entre les états
unis et la chine sur cette région en
afrique
effectivement ça il faut le reconnaître
la chine est très actif d agressive au
niveau de l'afrique australe et centrale
essart et solide il a laissé deux
milliers à l'essai de construction et
des btp mais aussi il faut reconnaître
aussi que les américains ils ont une
sainte rajout sur le plan non seulement
pétrolier et gazier au niveau du mosad
et qu'au niveau du kenya dans tous ces
gens là avec des entreprises américaines
dans les pauvres participé aussi à
saisir cette opportunité pour se
replacer et placer le entreprises je
pense que c'est une nouvelle
coopération et ses nouvelles stratégies
le diplomatie d'affaires qui consiste à
approcher et les pays
avec avec eux
renforcement des capacités économiques
fera profiter les entreprises
américaines de se positionner face à la
chine et à la tuque américains qui sont
en quête c'est un nouveau souffle en
afrique est-ce que ça va rompre ses
relations joe biden et son représentant
ces relations vont elles rompre avec
celle de donald trump en afrique
nous pouvons pas dire que ce sera une
rupture parce qu'en matière de gestion
étatique c'est de la continuité on peut
simplement dire que ils vont reprendre
les affaires les renforcer et nous
donner du nouveau coup leur haka vers de
nouvelles couleurs à travers
des coopérations comme
[Musique]
l'agoa qui existe depuis
presque dix huit ans 20 ans et qui aussi
voir aussi avec les millénium
m-66 comment faire pour renforcer
économiquement et
au d'auto
d'autres activités économiques qui
peuvent
profiter les amis merci beaucoup amadou
bâ pour votre et rh matin sur à fait
franc je le rappelle vous êtes chercheur
associé au groupe africa lips dakar